in Florida this afternoon SpaceX will
try again to launch into space history
never before is a company rather than a
country sent people into orbit this is a
live look at the Falcon 9 rocket
standing on the pad of Florida's Kennedy
Space Center if all goes well liftoff
will happen at 3:22 p.m. Eastern Time on
board will be two veteran NASA
astronauts the first attempt at launch
on Wednesday was scrubbed because of bad
weather everyone's hoping for a more
promising forecast today and that
includes our very own mark Strassmann
covering the launch for us at Kennedy
Space Center a good morning mark how are
the skies looking overhead good morning
Michelle officially weather conditions
are 5050 for launch today but I just
talked to a top NASA official right now
there's a call going on among all the
top officials here about the weather and
the official told me that right now it
launches looking more likely for
tomorrow than it is for today but no
final decision has been made yet what
everybody agrees about is that
astronauts safety trumps everything
launch conditions have to be favorable
both on pad 39a and in the Atlantic
Ocean all the way up the US East Coast
that's where the capsule would ditch in
case of serious trouble you don't have
to be a rocket scientist to grasp that
no one controls launch weather the human
factors end up adding some risk as well
because it wears everybody out including
our astronauts although they never
complain we won't we want to make sure
that everybody is well rested and ready
to go now do not expect to clear in time
to allow for a launch today Wednesday's
first launch attempt came oh so close
storms blew through and then with
astronauts Bob Behnken and Doug Hurley
strapped inside the crew Dragon capsule
and fueling underway an area near the
Space Center went under a tornado
warning SpaceX called it off 17 minutes
before liftoff
after clarity we are script for today's
launch today ignition lip-balm SpaceX
has launched cargo 20 times to the
International
Space Station only one of them didn't
make it and we pier to have had a launch
vehicle failure the company has never
faced a more critical test this capsule
will carry people before Wednesday's
launch attempt we talked about that with
SpaceX founder Elon Musk there's a
million things have to go right yes
there's thousands of things that can go
wrong and only one thing it could all
right that one thing is the safety of
the crew it is not simply the top
priority it is the only priority how
does that responsibility way up weighs
very heavily that's really all I can
think about right now so I really kind
of have to kind of mentally block it
because otherwise it would be
emotionally impossible to deal with this
launch has several firsts the first
liftoff of astronauts from US soil in
nearly a decade the first flight in a
new piloted spacecraft in almost 40
years and the first commercial launch of
people into orbit in this new age NASA
will become a customer and we want to
have numerous providers that are
competing on cost and innovation this is
the beginning of a commercial
marketplace in space so President Trump
and vice president Pence are supposed to
come back here to Kennedy Space Center
if the launch is a go to watch the to
watch it take off but if it's a no-go
Jeff the next attempt the third attempt
to make this happen will be tomorrow
afternoon
three o'clock Eastern marks Rosman
thanks very much